ciao ragazzi bentornato in una puntata
di b no di cucina è buttata tra 15 tieni
minuti io sarà online su instagram per
fare la mia puntata del fisico la copy
che potevi trovare da lunedì a sabato
insieme mio fratello insieme ai miei
fratelli in realtà nella quale è
fondamentalmente ci alleniamo e grazie
alla quale sta sviluppando un fisico da
covip pazzesco comunque siccome volevo
celebrare questo momento e volevo
utilizzare questi 50 minuti per riuscire
a fare girare un video e non buttare
completamente alba per questo momento
completamente passo avanti allo specchio
dicendo devo però un po meno gruppo mi
alleno ho pensato di preparare un dolce
un dolce dietetico pazzesco o no
soprattutto veloce perché riuscirò a
farlo in così poco tempo e che
fondamentalmente non perderà la sua
assomiglia sto parlando della torta pan
di stelle quando scade a dicembre 2019
al massimo per effetto non sono se quei
medicinali sta facendo perché formazione
prima di partire ieri notte qui cucina
esattamente libe caturano rosso xi con
le gambe lunga il corpo che si sente
investire anche il minuscolo chi mi
cerca
nessun il corpo di questi cose che
solitamente minuscolo perché hanno le
gambe lunghissime sembrava quello di una
tarantola per farvi nella larghezza la
grandezza di questo ragno io lucido ma
era una cosa mia perché ragno portà
guadagno e se avranno veramente protocol
anno in questo caso io sono pronto a
trasferirmi al colosseo per proprio
dentro il colosseo con lamborghini
utilizzo per passare dalla camera da
letto al bagno comunque bando alle
ciance lo stiamo parlando di me ma sto
parlando del gusto per fare la torta per
di stelle avremmo bisogno di pan di
stelle approvate il giorno che allatta
tanta panna non tenna e cacao amaro
fondamentalmente noi stiamo parlando di
tantissimi ingredienti sta parlando di
una ricetta poi senza brand importanti
cercando logo meglio che il lavoro
perché se no alla fine che non me le
nostre basse un'ottima scusa mi sono
fatto gli arrosticini prima st cucina
saadi alla stalla
senza contare che continuano a esserci
ovunque cerini cioè è diventata uno zoo
non so cosa fare
ma dove hanno messo le uova stica
insetti iniziamo per prima cosa prendete
una di queste qui quelli che sia
presente come si apre questo 70 beh non
lavoro che poi non ha più di chiudere
quel mano sola è iniziato a fare uno
strato ha mostrato di che vi chiederete
uno stato di compassione quindi piangete
ci sono tratti fatto ciò perché sa di
morte l'uomo dà gusto prendiamo il latte
i biscotti e apriamo a me per riuscire a
non mangiare niente perché se no
veramente cosa mito e tutto quanto
quando mandano veloci ragazzi per quando
diventare popolosi in giù piano piano
che nonni monet spade mettiamo sul fondo
vi faccio vedere io non do manger 1234
noi mettiamo sul fondo ora devo
migliorare la tecnica 44 44 beh avete
capito la cosa pallosa forse questa
ricetta è che un minimo dovrà poi
aspettare in frigo consolidarsi ma cosa
positiva che veramente è una cazzata di
proporzioni i signori bibliche la potete
fare i vostri figli con vostro nipote o
chiunque poi arriva un momento in cui
ovviamente essendo dei biscotti tondi vi
ritroverete davvero un sacco di sparsi
cosa prete in quel caso perdete biscotti
e spezzate e liszt spappolate un pochino
quasi a riempire un po tipo potevamo già
un po tipo base di cheesecake anno vi
faccio vedere sono le sole mani ancora
avesse fatto sette ore bdp questo sarà
più o meno il risultato finale ora non
dovete per forza inter e tutti quanti
buchi stica una volta fatto il primo
strato andiamo ad aprire landella mi
raccomando di tutti quanti i residui di
pellicola sopra perché quando la mettete
nel microonde laddove temi era
bassissima potenza verrà veramente poco
tempo giusto per farlo ammorbidire la
pellicola rischi di fare scintille a
chiedere di evitare di arrivare a questo
abbassano la potenza
nel frattempo oddio che succede
qualcosa che è successo che è successo è
successo che è successo ho sentito
qualcosa ragazzino che è successo è che
c'erano dei residui in poppa passi
decisivi pellicola stagione ha fatto
scintille
cosa facciamo questo punto prendiamo la
nutella
mammamia guardate quanto è deve essere
così ok è quello che va a fare grande la
nutella andare a metterla in giro dovete
un po andare occhio cioè non dovete
nemmeno esagerare ragazze perché poi
viene una roba stucchevoli sì ma io
l'amo ok io direi che ci possiamo
fermare stop ma ne voglia dire carlo non
farò troppi strati sia perché non
abbastanza da biscotti inzia perché sono
uno comunque ragazze c'è il rischio di
morire e sia perché preferisco po di
strati alti piuttosto che tantissimi
strati secchi asciutti come fanno alcuni
il tiramisù panna
io ho già messo due confezioni o dentro
e batteri
ok sono un pochino
non posso mangiarlo io per questa
allenamento mi statista allenamento vita
rovinando la vita quest'anno
inquadratura che fa un po schifo vi
chiedo perdono ma di meglio non potevo
fare prendiamo una spatola ea questo
punto andiamo abbondanti con la panna
inizialmente faccio così fossero montata
un po troppo indiano spalmare si può
fare di più senza se mi metto di più se
si stava facendo un launch cioè se
dobbiamo fare gli occhi col dolce fate
prima a fare un bicchiere d'acqua da
notare come la panna debba veramente
andare a coprire tutto quanto
e stato un errore non volevo farlo che
lo giuro andiamo avanti a testa alta
altri biscotti mettiamoli nel latte la
cosa positiva è che questa volta non
dobbiamo essere precisissimi con con i
bordi nel senso che ci possono essere
dei buchi anzi permetteranno al coltello
di affondare con più facilità quindi
tutti quelli che sono biscotti e rotti
invito di queste le cose che potete fare
quando state cucinando solamente per voi
esattamente mi invito a un maggiore
rispetto nei confronti di persone che
mangia scontri piatti finito c'è la
confezione questa è un po la situa
calcolate ragazzi è veramente questa è
abbastanza grande come abito a maggiore
e morigeratezza quindi cerca di fare un
po di meno che mai non fa altrimenti
prendete molta più panna un altro pacco
di pan di stelle se vuole proprio fare
una cosa su peralta della nutella
questo quindi abbondare voglio abbondare
voglio abbandonare quel lato è veramente
se uno si fa un morso di quella muore no
lei raccomando mai perdere la dignità in
cucina dai costi quel che costi
norda ma non ci sarebbe più sciolta
mamma mia mamma mia l'acqua frizzante
sgrassa che non meraviglia di nuovo una
sciacalla
una casacca da caracas e tre mesi una
musica allora questa qui l'ho fatta un
po più leggera leggermente meno vi
faccio vedere perché no vabbè no non
puntata leggermente di meno perché in
realtà è leggermente meno strutturata
sarà più facile spalmarla infatti
infatti adesso è facilissimo parlare o
primera meno facile da spalmare adesso è
lo strato superficiale una panna montata
così è molto più gestibile al fisco hi
fi lo strato di accedere che cosa
facciamo lo porta sulla davvero non lo
fate
se avete ospiti a casa ma io non ho pd
sono in quarantena non mi scrivo di me
stesso cerchiamo di fare una superficie
in periodo di altra possibile anzi non
mi faccio aiutare da un oggetto che ho
comprato in passato e non ho mai usato
[Musica]
buona della mamma da e carina pulisco il
bordeaux
lo scherzo il risultato finale apriamo
il frigo e c'è la v siamo dio dov'è qui
sopra facciamo un pochino di pulizia e
torno subito lavori anzi non mi sono
fatto quattro conti ho bisogno di 445 un
quarto d'ora per prepararmi
psicologicamente visto che oggi facciamo
un allenamento che è bambinelli dei
quindi staremo a fare addominali per
pancia realtà o bruciagrassi assurdo ho
detto pancia pianta pancia piange
comunque faccio l'allenamento e quindi
torno da voi perché ci sarà un momento
nel quale dovremo fare un pochino
melevisione se vogliamo provare la
presentazione quel dio che carina grazie
e poi è un ottimo spuntino dopo un
allenamento poi prendi quell'ora di
allenamento le blue chip sono tornato
abbiamo appena finito l'allenamento il
retablo vivono un po perché ho fatto
alcuna intervista per la setta dei libri
e veloso questo progetto comunque può un
foglio di tema che è diventato di colpo
l'albero azzurro no mi spiego ho una
superficie per poter tagliare un foglio
una penna scotch forbici o un taglierino
io preferisco iniziò a disegnare delle
stelle arc tac tac non devono essere
falsa belle va bene può essere disegnate
così possibile disegnata stella non
essere delle guide sono scusa devono
essere delle guide ed è a questo punto
prende il taglierino e vado a tagliarle
io mi sono già tutte le opere stanno
tagliando mano le forbici e taglierino
spigliata iniziate a ritagliare le
nostre stelle almeno se potete fare
mentre aspettate che la torta si
compatti alla fine ci ritroveremo queste
belle 10 stelline a siamo lo step
successivo spot delle strisce abbastanza
lunghe lo piegate perfettamente a metà
una parte
l'attaccate l'altra vc in trappola del
dito dentro pepe mi hanno fatto uscire
che mi hanno fatto uscire che però
voglio uscire finché l'ultimo progetto
la incollate alla stella ma anzi questa
cosa non è necessaria cioè fatenah
solamente se volete poco fa in fiki fiki
fiki però base essere ancora più figli
fate a
le vostre fare vere marcella fa qualcosa
e vi faccio vedere che cosa facciamo
adesso alla stellina è un po di scotch
che abbonda lo prendo le forbici in
tolgo il pezzo più abbondante cercando
di creare una sorta di unità di scotch e
vedete è una punti cina discorso qua si
vede bene questo che mi permetterà di
prelevare a stellina senza fare casino
almeno dovrebbe permettermi di farlo
secondo i miei piani perché non è una
cosa che ho fatto altre volte bisogna
dare una mano e basta andiamo a
prelevare la portata è la meta ricordato
così piatta
allora dico ce lo facciamo per rileviamo
le stelline vl posizioniamo mentre nella
torta daisy sterno leggermente per lei è
carina che si mi piace la sono contento
a questo punto prendo il cacao ma
insegna cina ne vado fashion e lo
potrete vedere come processo però vado a
setacciare è un po di cacao sopra la
torta
raccomando limpide per i voci evitate di
metterne troppo giusto quello che serve
per coprire il bianco ma fermatevi lice
datevi una regolata ecco sto mettendo in
realtà un boato bene e razzola male alla
fine questo procedimento avremo questo
gattino di lato super delicati vediamo
se funziona o non ha funzionato
questa funziona meglio da fare che ok
con la mezza nerd fare di più
mamma mia ok userò nella thumbnail una
foto finta modificherò per farvi credere
che siamo da perfetta prenderlo in giro
ti è che bella torta importante che sia
buona prova guardata così di sfuggita
sembrano tutte stelle guardavamo
comitato però sembra una stella momento
della vita tac piatto andiamo a fare
subito una fetta ma è consistenza
stupenda gara
vediamo se è stata abbastanza inserito
di s
mi sono reso conto di avere una macchia
in terre d'acqua maestro di averla avuta
per tutto il video e per tutto
l'allenamento comunque presa quella
nostra meravigliosa torta pan di stelle
prima di assaggiarla iscrivetevi a
questo canale se ne avete piacere
mettetemi un pollice in su per il perché
secondo me questa qui la tra due secondi
soprattutto ditemi se non è meravigliosa
fare un'associazione non c'è da
scommetterci così pannosa non respirando
da bere ispirati al cioccolato
mamma mia un bambino però respirata e
così come si respira una torta a tratti
ci vediamo martedì alle 12 con la maglia
ben altra ciao